i
[Música]
estas son las noticias de france 24 el
parlamento europeo decidió levantar la
inmunidad del ex presidente de la
generalitat de cataluña carles
puigdemont y sus dos exconsejeros
exiliados del desde el 2017 la decisión
permite reactivar los pedidos de
extradición de españa en una rueda de
prensa este monte indicó que se trata de
una persecución política de anunciaron
una demanda ante el tribunal europeo de
justicia
en brasil fue supremo anuló las condenas
en contra del ex presidente luiz inácio
lula da silva quien podría regresar a la
escena política del país incluso podría
aspirar a la presidencia en el 2022 la
decisión debe ser ratificada por el
pleno de una corte federal en brasilia
una instancia que va a evaluar este caso
analizamos el tema en minutos
y unos 320.000 ciudadanos venezolanos
aguardan la aprobación prevista para hoy
por parte del gobierno de eeuu de la
implementación del estatus de protección
temporal o tps que les permitirá residir
de manera legal en ese país
norteamericano hasta por 18 meses
tenemos los detalles
muy buenos días bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález vamos a comenzar en bruselas en
donde el parlamento europeo decidió
levantar la inmunidad del ex presidente
de la generalitat de cataluña carles
puigdemont y sus ex consejeros antoni
comín y clara ponsatí la decisión de la
eurocámara permite reactivar entonces
los procesos de extradición contra estos
tres funcionarios que son reclamados por
la justicia española después de haber
abandonado la región de cataluña en el
2017 tras haber impulsado el proceso
independentista de esa comunidad
autónoma hace unos minutos carles
puigdemont dio una rueda de prensa en la
que indicó que se trata de una
persecución política y anunció que
tomará medidas legales estas fueron sus
palabras naturalmente como en todos los
casos anteriores y naturalmente como en
los casos anteriores mis colegas y yo
estaremos a disposición de las
autoridades judiciales belgas otrabanda
nosotros presentaremos una demanda pero
por otro lado presentaremos una demanda
en contra de la decisión del parlamento
europeo en el tribunal europeo
justicia que es el único que puede
reparar el severo daño que se le ha
hecho a la democracia europea al quitar
la inmunidad a tres miembros del
parlamento por motivos políticos
vamos a conocer más detalles
relacionados con esta noticia del issga
zheng él se encuentra en barcelona en la
capacidad capital catalana ellis muy
buenas tardes para usted y veíamos a
carles puigdemont dando unas
declaraciones en una rueda de prensa que
más han dicho en esta rueda de prensa y
qué es lo que espera carles puigdemont
con este anuncio del parlamento europeo
y en esta rueda de prensa carles
puigdemont clara ponsatí toni comín el
primero de todo y son estos discursos en
varios idiomas en inglés en francés en
español y en catalán con el claro
propósito de internacionalizar todavía
más su causa y como lo acaban de
decisión pues yo me empezó a hablar él
dijo primero que agradecía las muestras
de apoyo que según él también pues son
una prueba del rechazo a lo que llaman
la represión contra la disidencia
política también dijo que hoy era un día
muy triste primero para ellos porque
pierden su inmunidad pero también dice
que es un día más triste todavía para el
parlamento europeo y también para la
democracia española como lo acaban de
comentar anunció un recurso ante el
tribunal de justicia europea y justo
después pues habló toni comín otro de
los eurodiputados catalanes y él quiso
recalcar sobre todo que el 42% de los
eurodiputados votaron en contra
de esta llegada de la inmunidad es el
porcentaje más alto que se haya visto
para este tipo de suplicatorio y segundo
eso es una muestra que no haya un
respaldo tan amplio a la justicia
española en el parlamento europeo
ellis este anuncio hecho desde bruselas
cómo ha caído como ha sido recibido
tanto en madrid como en barcelona porque
es un anuncio importante el que hizo el
parlamento europeo
pues sí como lo podéis adivinar aquí hay
reacciones de todo tipo desde esta
mañana por ejemplo donde me encuentro
ahora mismo frente al parlamento a la
sede del parlamento europeo en barcelona
pues hay una convocatoria de entidades
independentistas que emitieron una carta
a las máximas entidades europeas para
demostrar su rechazo a esta decisión
pero la primera reacción vino esta
mañana de la ministra de asuntos
exteriores española desde madrid ella
dijo que éste suplicatorio esta decisión
este voto del parlamento europeo
mostraba varias cosas una de ellas que
el conflicto catalán debía resolverse en
españa' con la justicia española aunque
todavía algo que despegara de decisiones
de la justicia belga y escocesa son
algunas de las reacciones desde la
ciudad de barcelona el issga single
dándonos detalles gracias al es por este
reporte vamos ahora con temas de américa
latina'
el ex presidente de brasil luiz inácio
lula da silva podría regresar al tablero
político de su país
un juez del supremo anuló las condenas
en su contra por corrupción si la
decisión es ratificada por la corte en
pleno a nivel federal lula dasilva
quedaría libre y podría presentarse así
a las elecciones presidenciales del 2022
el anuncio generó todo tipo de opiniones
políticas en brasil- entre ellas el
rechazo del actual presidente ya ir
bolsonaro para analizar este tema y el
alcance de esta medida saludamos al
señor ricardo seitenfus experto en
ciencia política y relaciones
internacionales nos atiende a esta hora
desde la ciudad de brasilia la capital
de brasil muy buenos días señor se
intensos gracias por estar con nosotros
en france 24 y qué tan factible es que
la corte federal hay en brasilia avale
esta decisión emitida por un juez
supremo que anuló estas condenas contra
el ex presidente lula da silva
buenos dias santiago los días oyentes es
casi seguro que si el pleno va a
reunirse porque la procuradoría general
de la república hizo la solicitud pues
está lista para hacer la solicitud para
ir a revisar la posición del juez aquí
pero todos los especialistas sobre la
actitud del supremo dicen que el supremo
va a confirmar esta decisión democrática
no el ministro joaquín y enseñarse en
tempos que significa para el pp el
partido de lula da silva el regreso o el
posible regreso de lula da silva la
escena política dado el contexto en el
que se encuentra brasil en donde está el
gobierno de bolsonaro donde hay una
crisis económica y donde está la crisis
sanitaria de la pandemia del cob y 19
para jesulín yo podría decir que
bolsonaro nació con el rechazo al pt y
anula y ahora vuelve a el renacimiento
de las cenizas de lula y del pp con el
rechazo a bolsonaro o sea una dialéctica
santiago entre los dos hombres y
seguramente a esto la decisión que se
tomó es un sismo político porque hasta
ahora no había ningún candidato que
podría tener alguna posibilidad de
victoria frente a versionar y 2022
por ahora lula es casi seguro que se me
ocurre se verá como candidato y muy
probablemente va a volver a la
presidencia de brasil porque esta
decisión en este momento cuando estamos
prácticamente a un año de que finalice
la presidencia de bolsonaro esto tendría
intenciones políticas dado que las
elecciones están solamente a la vuelta
de la esquina que piensa usted
un juego entre política y derecho
hay muchos jueces que hacen política y
hay muchos políticos que hacen
justicia que hace cosas de derecho a la
frontera entre los dos es muy muy débil
y hoy
dirige como los animales cuando son
incubados con una enfermedad conmovidos
reacción con autodefensas
los dos cuerpos los cuerpos sociales de
bien reacción
y esto como una reacción del cuerpo
social brasilero
la decisión de fuckin pérez es muy
aceptada y brasil hay la idea sabían que
se puede perder los anillos pero no se
puede perder los de ellos lo que de que
su gestión y muy bien esa situación de
inversión de valores y de aceptar que la
lucha contra la corrupción es limitada
quizás no va más adelante se va a alejar
de salida porque porque tenemos un otro
adversario mucho más fuerte mucho más
importante mucho más peligroso y el
gobierno de brasil por esto que hago
esta relación entre enfermedad inter
vacuna y política señor ricardo se
intensos en la ciudad de brasilia
gracias por este análisis para nuestra
audiencia en américa latina sobre este
tema relacionado al ex presidente de
brasil luiz inácio lula
avanzamos con otros temas en mexico la
marcha con motivo del día internacional
de la mujer dejó 81 mujeres heridas
entre ellas varias policías y
manifestantes varias de ellas tuvieron
que ser trasladadas a diferentes centros
asistenciales durante algunas de las
protestas en la región de américa
latina' miles de mujeres levantaron su
voz para alertar para reivindicar sus
derechos andrés amaya hace un recuento
de esta jornada en la región de américa
latina'
no es un muro de paz como el presidente
de mexico lo llamo es una de las tantas
divisiones que las autoridades
instalaron para evitar el paso de los
manifestantes en ciudad de mexico el día
internacional de la mujer en el país de
américa latina que más casos de
feminicidio registra se celebró con ir a
la misma que se siente al saber que
cerca de 1000 mujeres fueron asesinadas
en 2020 solamente es el hecho de que se
tome una precaución en cuanto a escuchar
lo que se pide y algo que se pide es una
seguridad mayor para que nosotros
podamos ir caminando para que podamos ir
con nuestra vida como cualquier otra
persona en bolivia numerosos colectivos
feministas marcharon el país andino
registra en lo que va del año 300 51
casos de violaciones a mujeres y 342 de
abuso sexual
y una mujer más adinerada está
aunque nosotros nos duele nos duele lo
que nos hacen que nos peguen que nos
violen y que el estado no haga nada y
que de paso los jueces liberen a los
violentos lo que prometieron para
constitucional
y por mis hijas mi madre por mi abuela
en venezuela a pesar de que el
presidente nicolás maduro prohibió las
concentraciones varios grupos opositores
y de feministas organizaron pequeñas
manifestaciones
jóvenes en el país nos levantamos
le decimos al pueblo venezolano
futura venezuela pero hay que pelearlo
en brasil decenas de personas marcharon
con cruces negras para recordar los 649
feminicidios que hubo durante el primer
semestre de 2020 y en argentina tras la
legalización del aborto a finales de
2020 los movimientos feministas
aprovecharon la celebración
internacional para pedir equidad
salarial y más protección ante una tasa
elevada de feminicidios a pesar de las
medidas de confinamiento por la pandemia
de kobe 19 cada 30 horas una mujer es
asesinada en argentina aproximadamente
en otros temas se espera que para la
jornada de hoy el gobierno de eeuu
apruebe la implementación del estatus de
protección temporal tps en inglés para
unos 320.000 ciudadanos venezolanos que
podrían residir en ese país por más de
18 meses de manera legal
el informe de luís muñoz un respiro para
los venezolanos en eeuu el gobierno de
yubá idem anunció que 320 mil
venezolanos podrán acogerse al estatus
de protección temporal que les permitirá
trabajar y residir legalmente en el país
hay una compleja situación humanitaria
con hambre extendida malnutrición y la
creciente presencia de grupos armados no
estatales e infraestructuras en ruinas
la medida tendrá una vigencia de 18
meses prorrogables y la podrán solicitar
los que estén en eeuu desde antes del
lunes 8 de marzo desde su publicación
este martes los venezolanos tendrán 180
días para acogerse al programa tendrán
que demostrar no tener antecedentes
penales y tendrán que pagar tasas de
unos 535 dólares
dos venezolanos que residen en eeuu
celebraron la medida
y hay mucha gente que no tiene la plata
para pedirlas y luego van llegando y no
saben qué hacer entiende la medida pone
de acuerdo a republicanos y demócratas
desde venezuela el opositor juan guaidó
agradeció a eeuu relaciones mientras que
el canciller jorge arreaza instó a la
casablanca a retirar las sanciones señor
secretario blinken en aras de la
coherencia lo que debería exigirse es
que así como la onu ha exigido su
administración levante inmediatamente
las crueles sanciones que han generado
todo tipo de dificultades y dolor a la
gente así como serias restricciones e
impactos en la economía venezolana el
estatus de protección temporal es un
programa migratorio creado en 1990 que
tiene por objetivo conceder permisos a
inmigrantes de naciones a las que no es
seguro volver según la onu venezuela
vive una de las peores crisis
humanitarias del mundo y alrededor de 54
millones de venezolanos han dejado el
país en los últimos años
ponemos punto final a las noticias de
france 24 siga con nuestra programación
buenos días
[Música]